alright guys I'm here with Cathy we have
a whole lot to cover before we jump into
all the fun stuff maybe just tell
everyone your background and what arc
invest is and kind of how you guys have
built this amazing organization great
well I'm happy to be here Anthony thank
you for inviting me
I started arc five years ago we had a
5th year anniversary January
congratulations thank you it's been a
lot of fun and a lot of hard work I
don't want you preneur ever says a time
like an anniversary without taking a
deep breath yes three of which I funded
myself so you know I was and it was
during the risk-on risk-off parts of the
market but I started the firm for two
reasons one was to focus solely on
disruptive innovation it's a void in
research I believe in our market and I'm
finding that the appetite for this kind
of research is much greater with the
retail investor than the institutional
investor and we're trying to change that
we're trying to change that yeah it's
because institutions are going passive
they're giving up right and you're just
mimic and index and you don't have to do
much more than that that's an
oversimplification but for those who are
who say they're active and are very
benchmark sensitive I think that's just
as bad it's a misallocation of capital
so I felt very strongly about that and
that innovation we needed to support in
the public markets and the the
opportunities that were evolving were so
enormous that they needed to be surfaced
researched they needed to be shared
these opportunities and so that was the
prime reason and the second reason was
to add new dimensions to research
the world is changing so rapidly Moore's
law to something faster right and that's
very fast traditional research houses
cannot they are not organized now and I
don't think they will be organized for a
long time to research innovation the way
it needs to be researched and by that I
mean we've got technology seeping into
every sector so every analyst really has
to become a technology analyst we don't
have that right now we have extreme
specialization and very short term focus
and do you think that that kind of
structural issue that's not just one
firm that does it that's pretty much
industry why yes is that something that
is based on a belief that is untrue like
so a bunch of these people who run the
firm's think that that's the best way to
do it and they're just wrong or there's
a better way or do you think that there
are certain advantages from that
structure that maybe aren't applicable
to what you're trying to accomplish like
how do you compare that model to what
you're doing so we are doing something
different and they are set up more
around benchmarks we are not we I don't
even know what's in benchmarks and I
don't care what's in a benchmark so if
that is the the goal they the objective
they've set is to be as close to
something that people understand and are
comfortable with if that's our objective
then they're set up correctly if their
objective is to maximize returns on
capital
I think we've set up the the right
structure because for a couple of
reasons one that there are five
platforms evolving at the same time
today technologically enabled platforms
that are going to scale to the multiple
trillions of dollars from you know maybe
billions now because one of the things
that the reason I'm so excited to talk
to you guys this is one of the
conversations I'm probably the most
excited to have
you're not a crypto investor you're not
a blockchain investor right you look
very much at the macro landscape of
disruptive and innovative technology and
you come at it from a world where you've
identified these five platforms that we
can talk about but you don't look at it
as the technologies are siloed you
actually look at how they overlap how
they interact integration verging and so
maybe let's start with what are the five
platforms so we can kind of go through
each one of them and then we can get to
you know how does that actually manifest
in the interaction or the integration of
them right so technology seeping into
every sector and then these five
platforms converging it's these are
phenomenal opportunities but traditional
research is not set up to capitalize on
them so the five platforms are DNA
sequencing so now we are going to bring
real science into healthcare
decision-making we're gonna have
information we can act on like Oh from
from this physical exam to that physical
exam these mutations surfaced mutations
are the first sign of disease oh okay
what we can what can we do about that
all right
CRISPR gene editing technology we can
correct those programming errors and
potentially cure this disease or this
emerging problem it's funny you say
programming because it leads me to
believe you probably think humans are
just a different form of a computer
right I mean that's how we are three
billion pieces of code in our in our DNA
absolutely and any one of them can go
haywire we can have a mutation and
wouldn't you like to have wouldn't you
like to be able to correct a programming
error that's what we usually well that's
the science that's emerging but it
couldn't have emerged without the
sequencing technology first and foremost
so that is the V major that's the
foundational platform then you've got
off of it CRISPR gene editing and cartee
technologies and so forth
so DNA sequencing robotics a lot of
people think okay robots have been
around
long time and they have they have
industrial robots are primarily in
mature industries like autos very mature
auto sales have peaked we believe so
however collaborative robots are
surfacing Tara Dean is the biggest
manufacturer has about 60% market share
which means these robots will drop to
about $10,000 per robot and and what is
one robot like that do with it will an
assembly line worker can train the robot
to to do his or her job like pick and
place pick in place they can do 24/7 no
bathroom breaks no vacation maybe
occasional maintenance but a lot of
people say this is terrible this is
terrible but this is gonna kill jobs and
the history of technology is there's
displacement that is true but technology
always creates jobs and we've got a few
pieces talking about that up on our
website at arc - invest so collaborative
robots are going to enter every industry
and so we're pretty excited by that and
and love the idea that most people don't
even know what a co bot is and certainly
don't know the company that manufactures
these because it's a semiconductor test
company and the so I think a lot of
people to know what a robot is and they
might have different variations of that
in their mind but a collaborative robot
is the collaborative word descriptive of
the ability for humans and robots to
collaborate together exactly so that's
the training element absolute training
and helping leveraging the humans
capabilities it's almost it sounds more
there's augmentation in the beginning of
the human then there is eventually
duplication and actually replacement of
the human and the human can go do
something else
yeah higher value add always moving
higher
it's when you talk about the jobs thing
I believe that this is correct
I've had multiple people tell me this
when the ATMs came out in the banking
industry there was a we're not gonna
need bank branches right the bank
tellers absolutely done yes there's more
bank tellers today than there were
before ATMs absolutely identity to your
idea of it creates more jobs actually
increases the access the adoption of the
writing system etc I think there's
plenty of examples it you know he'd go
through yeah yes and we always went when
we hear that fear we say okay listen the
tractor if the poppy if the population
in the United States had been as large
today as a then what we would have seen
the number of jobs lost would would have
been for that time remember we were
agrarian about forty million in today's
terms forty million jobs now yes a lot
changed and if you look back in the late
1800s Early 1900s there was a lot of
social uncertainty and you know there
was nervousness and unrest but as it
turned out we ended up the end of that
period after the internal combustion
engine electricity and telephone the
last time we had multiple innovation
platforms evolving at the same time we
have five now we believe back then we
ended up in the Roaring Twenties right
so boom and if you look back then it
explains all kinds of things that are
going on right now you know people are
worried everyday about the yield curve
well guess what the yield curve was
inverted half the time when the economy
was booming with innovation and we can
talk about that but it's the underlying
deflationary impact good deflation of
innovation for sure so we have DNA
sequencing robotics water and we throw
into robotics other automation like 3d
printing that's the third major platform
is energy storage
so this is where Elon Musk comes in and
he really has accelerated the cost
declines in battery technology
and and not just the battery cells
themself selves it's more the battery
pack system do you remember when Elon
first proposed his electric vehicle and
he was going to line the bottom of the
car with cellphone batteries and do you
remember how many people made fun of him
including other automakers okay he did
it it worked no one else is doing it
they didn't think it was possible he has
a huge competitive advantage
he's also accelerating the cost curve
decline or perpetuating it so that by
the early 2020s an electric vehicle the
average electric vehicle will be cheaper
than a gas powered vehicle that's
probably 2021 or 2022 not too far what
you don't hear say but we should say
more is that the electric vehicle price
will continue to fall while the internal
combustion engine powered car price will
continue to move up so so you think
there's actually opposite effects
happening you think the electric car
think most people think okay it's gonna
continue to go down over time but you
think that the the gas powered cars will
continue to increase in price what what
what drives it you get the emissions
scandal like we saw in Europe you get
tighter regulation around the world so
that more regulation means higher costs
so that's one of the main ones plus raw
material costs they don't have it's a
mature technology they don't have a
technology cost curve to fall down it's
mature so we think that by the Year 2023
there will be assuming we have the
batteries the demand based on the price
of an electric vehicle for electric
vehicles will be twenty six million
units last year it was 1.3 million so 20
fold increase in five years right
that happens to be good to be building
electric vehicles correct correct and
and we would predict a lot of
destruction in the traditional auto
industry we think most of them will go
bankrupt or consolidate or they'll
insinuate themselves into an autonomous
taxing Network ecosystem for example GM
has cruise automation it's do its
partnering with lyft way moe I think
also as a partnership with left I know
they're there there's a lot there are a
lot of confusing things from an
ecosystem going well they're trying to
figure out how they're going to survive
is basically what's going on
and they think that those efforts that
the who's actually automated I've never
actually thought about this but the
automotive industry is very analogous to
the crypto industry in that you have you
know banks and legacy financial systems
you've got legacy automotive industry
and you've got these new challengers new
technology kind of different completely
dismissed yep dismiss people laugh at it
adverse all that stuff yeah in crypto
we're now starting to see you know
JPMorgan they want to their own coin
right we can get into all that but in
the automotive industry how serious of a
competitor in the marketplace are the
legacy automotive companies that are
doing electric I was call initiatives
that some of them are building car some
are doing more around automation
whatever but just how serious are those
efforts compared to the upstart
challengers well they're becoming much
more serious because you're getting
Toyota talking to the head of North
America Toyota talking about Prius sales
being down 9% and they in tribute half
of that decline to Tesla Wow right so
you've got some of it and you've got in
Germany you've got the Ministry of Trade
has come out and said okay we have to
start supporting these new technologies
so that German industry is not left
behind and we think that we think
they're talking primarily about the auto
industry because it's in trouble it's in
trouble not just because of the emission
standards although I've been thinking
the emission scandal
is going to force them to change the
subject and move
maybe pivot more aggressively to
electric vehicles then our auto
manufacturers have and to some extent
that's true but I think everyone's
running scared now and you know the
question we used to get about Tesla all
the time was wait a minute these
companies are in D budgets would run
circles around Tesla sales its revenues
and our answer was wrong DNA for the
world we're entering into you you don't
need the kind of hardware engineers that
these companies have you need more
electrical and software engineers in
short yes returns short supply so we we
have we should always take competition
seriously and especially from the old
guard because my experience investing in
disruptive innovation is the old guard
in order to stop the new guard will say
and this goes back to your JP Morgan a
question here will say hey we're gonna
do that we're we're just we're just
gonna do it our way our way and it's
gonna be so much cheaper and we're gonna
wipe them off the face of the earth that
is not a sustainable company so that now
I think we're we've passed that test
with Tesla but that you do know that's
was a lot of last year it was exactly
about is this a viable company and I was
also push first poll right like like
entrepreneurs that are disruptive bust
their way into an industry I'm gonna go
build this I'm gonna improve this I'm
gonna disrupt this and it is very
self-motivated mm-hmm whereas the
incumbents tend to be very poll oriented
and they're like I'm getting pulled into
doing electric cars mini poll they for
the most part don't desire to do that
right they actually love the business
model they had right same thing in
finance etc yeah okay so we've got DNA
sequence robotics energy storage fourth
platform just one test I'm going to
answer one more reason it is
away from the pack okay oh there are
there are three major reasons one it has
the lowest cost battery and it is
accelerating the technology changes in
battery technology so that it's at least
three years ahead of any other auto
manufacturer it's the only one building
batteries the way it has leveraging off
the consumer electronics industry
everyone else is using prismatic
batteries they're using cylindrical
batteries so they're writing down a cost
curve that was sent a long time ago
number two they released their own
artificial intelligence chip this summer
right around the time of the famous
tweet so in our scoring system you know
the management score went down a bit
because yes we do not want distractions
like this especially not with the SEC
involved but another one of our scores
barriers to entry or moat went up
because this AI chip which on our
podcast last week Ilan said was 20 had
20 times the power of the Nvidia chip
that he was pulling out 20 times and we
were talking about just so people
understand this because not that many
people are familiar with electric
vehicles and I frankly am a complete
novice compared to you is they were
using a component this Nvidia chip that
they were sourcing putting in the cars
and while using that chip over the last
couple of years they've actually created
their own proprietary chips yes and they
have now executed the ripping out or the
the cease of use of the Nvidia chip and
they now have their own that will take
place later this year but our analyst
who worked at Nvidia for nine years he
took a look at the specs and he said
this is going to put them three years
ahead of any other auto manufacturer
when it comes to the artificial
intelligence or deep learning or neural
networks that you need if you're going
to host an autonomous taxi network
platform that's what Tesla is going to
do and the the what that what powers an
autonomous vehicle is artificial
intelligence
and then that takes us to the third
reason Tesla's way ahead of anybody else
Tesla has collected and we confirmed
this in our call or podcast last week
eight billion miles worth of data I
think the closest is Google with a
hundred million something that order of
macro and the the competitive advantage
that Tesla has is I am going out there
every day and my model three collecting
data for them and sending it back every
day it's automatic
whereas Google's doing pilot tests okay
so I have two questions one is the eight
billion or whatever the number is from
Tesla that is not simulated data that is
actual real traction on the road real
driving on the road and they have
somewhat of a decentralized approach to
it in that they sell cars those cars are
driven by everyday people exactly had
nothing to do with Tesla how to do and
their customer mmm-hmm and the car is
collecting that data and sending it back
yes you the company whereas Google these
pilots are talking about these are the
funny-looking cars that a Google
employee gets in they autonomously drive
through the streets of whatever city but
there's only so many of them they're
very kind of centralized if you know in
terms of the way that they run this very
much so very controlling it's
fascinating as we're talking more how
much overlap and kind of analogous you
know applications there are for what's
happening in crypto to all these other
deranged right Tesla did or is doing to
the electric vehicle space what Apple
did to the cell phone smart nor Tesla is
hat is designing its own AI chip deep
learning chip because it knows where it
wants to take the ecosystem and it want
and knows how fast it can move which is
not at the cadence of the traditional
auto industry like five times faster
right and so it had to design its own AI
chip to move fast enough Nvidia will
have the rest of the auto
world that most other auto companies
will build using invidious chip and
we're optimistic about that to some
extent I mean Tesla is not going to be
the only car manufacturer others will
figure this out so do you remember I
don't know if you had this experience
you might have been too young but I
certainly did so I got my smartphone and
I looked at it and I said wait a minute
can I access the internet from this
phone oh my goodness I couldn't believe
it I just didn't believe it that was
that was the smart phone moment that was
the iPhone moment for me you get into a
Tesla car and it's great you can go back
to any other car there are so many aha
are you kidding me moments and I haven't
even gone through all of the video to
figure this all out in fact I'm
embarrassed at how little I've done of
that but I'm a point A to B person and
time is money I'm kidding but anyway I
must study it so they had to they had to
design their own ship in order to not
only create that experience the these
experiences that that we're gonna see
from Tesla are going to be mind-blowing
well he look he is I'm fascinated by
Elon for a whole bunch of different
things but one of the things I think
most even the detractors can't argue
with is his ability to think from first
principles first prints and what you're
describing is okay NVIDIA is providing
me this chip I'm limited in the amount
of innovation and the acceleration of
what I want to do by that chip I can
either encourage them to speed it up or
I can just go build my own if I build it
better I can custom butter for what I
need a faster pace was just good Apple
at all yeah so Apple did it he did even
also does with rockets yes Oh with the
holes of her business well what's the
problem the Rockets are expensive why
are they expensive because you can't
reuse them a reasonable how
using right well flying on a drone in
the ocean it's incredible how once he's
learned that mental model and applied it
and had success he just data point of a
data point for data point he continued
to do this so and it's all it's not only
that they have a technology advantage
right there's a mindset or Ordnung
pletely different mindsets -
intelligence as much as it's just the
way that they think right and that
allows them to make decisions that other
people probably would either think was
crazy or wouldn't pursue right yeah it's
um it's funny because there's a guy in
crypto a Nathanael who said the other
day he said legacy thinking is a
liability absolutely right yes and I
literally just smiled to myself and I
said that should become a thing because
that could not be more true in terms of
every industry but crypto specifically
well and uh as you say that what we have
done in terms of research is go back to
first principles research that has been
lost in our industry we all of our
modeling is original modeling and I'm
not talking about the bottom-up models
I'm talking about the top-down ones
sizing how big will this opportunity be
right we think the autonomous taxi
Network platform that market will be an
eight trillion dollar market it trillion
dollars now that's out a couple of
decades from now but you can do pretty
good cash flow analysis on that model
it's a software-as-a-service model and
it's highly profitable no one has been
willing to do that with Tesla because
they've been focused on this year and
cash and production but to your point if
if Elon could land the Falcon Heavy to
two of them on a barge at the same time
I think he can rant production of the
model 3i that was my mantra and people
are saying up with them he's gonna run
out of money and I said is the equity
market shutting down he can run he can
he can raise my
at a price yes we would be a buyer at if
they were going to crater the stock on
that those are the great opportunities
we trade around those opportunities all
the time we we talked about before we
started Amazon stock is a perfect
example yeah right you know the data
points in many of you've heard me say
this before the intra year average
drawdown for the last 20-something years
it's like 30 plus percent that means one
time a year at least they've gone down
30 plus percent and twice they've gone
down over 90 percent that wasn't because
Amazon was a horrible business it was
because there was macro market you know
movements that caused that there was
financing needs there retail the
traditional retails were going to kill
them remember I went through it with the
entire time we owned it from the
beginning so I went through those draw
downs and when you invest in innovation
what you learn to do with them is use
them right
you use them you lean into them if
that's the if that if Amazon is going to
be the number one retailer globally but
let's just say in the United States then
I'm going to use every one of those
downturns to increase it back to my top
position
yep and your dollar cost averaging the
purchase of more shares right when
everyone else is getting fearful you
start getting greedy and we do the
opposite when everyone starts
hyperventilating about one of our stocks
and takes them to the moon we know
there's another side to this and we'll
have another opportunity and now I've
known I've gotten a lot of questions
about Tesla and our trading around Tesla
because we do report our trading every
day and disclose our holdings every day
in the fourth quarter
Nvidia dropped it's not exactly fourth
quarter but the period of time I'm
talking about when Tesla was went up 53%
from that moment in August when we were
going through the tweet problem it was
up 53% by early December Nvidia was down
almost 40% I'm
boy yo manager up 50% down 40% I know
what to do with that trade especially
since they're focused on the same space
right there's just there's too much of a
very variation between two stocks that
should be somewhat correlated well in
video was being taken down by crypto so
which was such a short term reason short
term reason because it barely registered
but it did back up into the gaming the
GPU in whoever was doing the earnings
calls they were talking more about it
than it will probably deserved as part
of their revenue right there it was the
sexy thing everyone was asking questions
about it and so it kind of dominated
more of a call than probably was
appropriate so I was surprised
so they mentioned memento positively in
two calls I forget the exact quarters
probably the fourth quarter of 17 and
the fourth or maybe was the first
quarter of 18 and the second quarter and
when they did they they never had
mentioned crypto before because it
wasn't a needle mover so he said okay
needle mover that's interesting and then
they again in the next quarter they
mentioned it positively and believe it
or not it is for that reason that I
started taking our position down so
Nvidia was it was it was in the six to
seven percent range of our portfolio we
took it down to a 1% and then in October
when it started crashing because finally
in that quarter when they announced that
quarter and said oh you know this is
much bigger than we thought it was it
backed up into the gaming GPU inventory
and now we have this overhang and I
don't know when it's going to clear so
we used that controversy to build it
back now it's back at 6% yeah and so
what she's describing here is basically
through the end of 17 and even into like
the first month or two of 18 there was
an incredible unpredicted demand
for GPU cars which are used in crypto
mining and also for videogames and
things like that but as these companies
saw that demand ramping they basically
said hey manufacture more we're gonna
have all this demand by the time they
got that inventory ready to sell the
demand had dissipated because the price
has started dropping incoming profitable
and so all of a sudden you had these GPU
manufacturers sitting there with a ton
of inventory that they couldn't sell and
so do you discount it do you don't you
know what do you do and that's one of
the things that we think a lot about is
just what is the difference between the
way that a legacy business like that has
to run a manufacturing process it takes
time to lag then the reporting of that
performance compared to the incredible
speed of an iteration of crypto markets
that are 24/7 365
you know Bitcoin can move 6% in a day
and then go the other way 10% the next
day right it's completely different
mismatch of speed and timing the other
absolutely the other thing that was
happening is a lot of the new projects
being announced with these new coins
we're being built on top of aetherium
and so therefore GPU based yep and we
were very uncomfortable with that very
very uncomfortable I've been around the
track a few times I've been in the
business a few long enough to know if
there's real speculation like we saw
there is going to be fallout and it's
going to last longer and so I'm not
telling you I called it perfectly and we
would never have let go of all of NVIDIA
just because it is core to us in many
ways it's not just its artificial
intelligence period so so we would never
have liked it but I didn't like this
speculation worried about the ICO craze
and knew I didn't know how badly and I'm
not patting myself on the back at all
it's just you know as a portfolio
manager okay that went too far and we
don't know the last of it yet okay so
let's get back to the DNA sequencing
robotics energy storage
the next one is we call it in a
broad-brush way next generation internet
so we feature today deep learning on
that and the reason we're featuring deep
learning is it's ready for primetime so
artificial intelligence has been around
for a long time right it's been great
for science fiction but we really didn't
see it in our lives you know it was why
is it happening now why are we ready for
primetime we're ready for primetime
because we've taken the human programmer
out of the equation so what you need for
deep learning and neural networks is you
need Big Data we have a lot of that we
need algorithms that will iterate as the
machine is is optimizing to some goal
and we need supercomputing power right
and so those are occurring human
programmers actually held us back
because they cannot imagine this goes
back to your decentralized I know you're
going to bring this thread in they
cannot imagine every eventualities out
there of course they can't and you know
that's that's why open source the
movement started in the first place
people couldn't get their projects done
researchers couldn't get their projects
done they were trying to accelerate them
so you know and blockchain technology
the whole movement is exploding there it
makes a lot of sense it's funny because
if you look at the companies that have
been successful and you know what I'll
call kind of web 2.0 right so this is
the Facebook's the Twitter's etc what
most of them did very successfully in
one former fashion was they created a
platform strategy right they said you
know facebook said look okay you guys
are all gonna sign up for profiles they
tied it together right with the newsfeed
so it's kind of their one competitive
advantage over myspace was this idea of
real identity tied together and really
lock people into the network but when
they opened up the platform they knew
people wanted to build games right they
could have built the games themselves
but instead they said we're gonna give
you the tools to build and then all of a
sudden you realize oh there's some
person in
you know Wichita building something
there's somebody down the street in San
Francisco building so yeah somebody in
New York this building something that
they want right and what you get is by
providing the critical tools to these
people with the platform strategy it's
the only things that you can't imagine
the pace of the development seller is
unmatched machine learning AI all this
stuff the part to me that the example I
always go back in my head is I've been a
part of some some teams that frankly I
probably should have been a part of in
this growth side of the internet right
so Facebook etc and one of the things
that we always had to do is we had to
come up with tests there's a bunch of
traffic going to a webpage and you know
how do I get somebody to click on this
button more often well you come up with
150 different variations of that button
so what color is that what shade is that
what font what size is that corner you
know I rounded corners flat corners and
shadows are not chef yeah and then you
take all the variables and then you run
all these tests a human had to come up
with all of those very variables yeah a
machine can do it better
oh yeah right it's not even close and
they can come up with the very of the
variations faster and they can get the
traffic there and you will get a better
outcome by basically handing it over to
the machines that methodically and
programmatically go through that rather
than you and I so without a doubt
without a doubt
Einstein so Salesforce calms AI offer a
great name it's a great name it's a
great name they've gone from a billion
queries per day I think this is it's
gone up a billion per quarter Wow so I
mean it's really taking off they're
going up a billion no it's a billion per
day oh and there was two billion then it
was three billion I don't know if we've
hit the four billion you got it okay got
it but I mean this thing is exploding
quarter the daily yeah queries a double
minute yeah fifty percent you got it wow
that's really impressive okay so we've
got DNA sequencing we've got robotics
we've got energy storage we've got
next-gen computing which is deep
learning and
it's technically some people point out
to me that blockchain technology should
be part of the next generation Internet
I mean it is true that the internet was
not conceived with commerce in mind just
information you know I was listening to
Steve Case at a conference recently and
he said I didn't know this I didn't
remember this even though I was
investing at the time it was not legal
for consumers to use the internet until
1991 Wow
I didn't know I was in the business at
that time I just started managing money
right it was not legal until there was
some telecom Act passed that's that's
great that's how recent this is yes so
back then it was academia government you
know it was probably secretive some of
it all the bad people were using yes
well sounds just like all of that before
using it and so of course it didn't have
commerce in mind at the time nobody even
conceived of it and so now we're we're
filling that vacuum and it's a great
thing and it's funny too because there's
a there's a kind of ying ying yang I
think in the Internet's development of
so you know 91 let's say the the
consumer now can use this for commerce
all of a sudden you start to see better
user experiences and interfaces right
then you see the consumers start to want
to do other things right and you see
improvement there and you get this kind
of you know the users want something and
then it takes some time for the
infrastructure to catch up right and the
users want something else
sure like crypto and blockchain is
following this to a tee absolutely
everyone wants to do certain things
infrastructure is not there yeah
enforcer catch up we go again why do you
guys take so the fifth platform is
blockchain yeah why don't you take that
out no you mean away from the
organization because we think it's going
to be it's good it represents such a
profound change that people just do not
understand people do not understand and
yeah yes you know
our crypto analyst who took over from
Chris Byrne iski Chris hand-picked him
he surfaced a number that I think well
it exploded it for me in terms of
importance last year there were 1.4
trillion dollars in transactions over
the Bitcoin blockchain now and and each
transaction the average size of the
transaction was fifteen thousand dollars
so I get a lot of people coming back to
me and saying yeah drugs and all of that
stuff no no there are other darker less
transparent places to maybe do that send
all the haters my I'm very well versed
in how to deal with these people yes no
this is business to business in Africa
it's impossible to [ __ ] to convert from
one currency to the other you have to go
through the dollar you have to pay tolls
they're eight up to 25% and these this
is a huge unmet need no financial
infrastructure so what that speaks
volumes you've got PayPal at half of
that o we go right online
you've got PayPal venmo Apple pay right
yeah yeah them all the Bitcoin network
the transaction settlement network I
think the last number I saw was over 410
billion in 2018 so through the doubt and
you know the downturn reset your four
hundred ten billion dollars of annual
transaction volume blows those other
ones away it's not even close so yeah
see maybe we should compare research
because yeah scenes number is one point
three six trillion dollars I like that
number even been no and and he can show
you he can show you that so when I saw
that I was thinking we'll wait a minute
visa
is not even an order of magnitude
greater and and we know that you know
especially if we were to get this the
ecosystem settled down which it seems to
be doing we know it's you know this is
just the tip of the iceberg that was
last year I mean I believe that
blockchain technology today is where the
World Wide Web was maybe in the early
90s maybe earlier and if if I had seen
transactions worth 1.3 trillion dollars
back then at that time I said oh my gosh
this is going to be this is huge this is
going to be even today I find it hard to
believe but the fact that that has taken
place tells me yeah there's a lot of
turmoil in the world huge unmet needs
we've also done a lot of work on mobile
payments so this would be a 10 cent you
know Ali pay so China accounts for 92%
of all mobile payments in the world
today yet China's economy is 13 trillion
dollars their GDP what do you think the
mobile payment volume in China is or was
in 2018 so their GDP is thirteen
trillion dollars I'm gonna cheek cuz we
just talked to somebody from from China
and they told us that it was such a big
percentage I'll go with half how about
two times 24 trillion now why is this
because GDP only measures activity if
you go from raw materials to work in
process okay that's one number and then
say in the next quarter you go from
working process to finished only that
stage gets into the GDP from work from
work in process progress to finished
goods but the entire value of it has to
go through the mobile payment system
right right so cuz it's going from one
user to another to as a consumer
that's so what we're talking about here
is could be multiple trillions mobile
payments themselves this is that this is
the precursor to you know an ever better
solution in blockchain technology that
could be multiples of global GDP global
GDP is about eighty three trillion
dollars now so we are talking about two
hundred and fifty trillion dollars and
then then you also have to include
tipping which we don't do and red
envelope day gifting in China that they
do so I think that the numbers out there
that will be attached to this ecosystem
are far beyond what anyone is thinking
right now it's so funny to hear you say
this because you're saying something
that I think a lot of people who are
looking at this one point in time or
like what the hell are they talking
about but if you kind of zoom out on the
timeline of disruptive technology we
have seen this over and over and over
again and so let's go back to Oberon
lift when investors first saw those
companies if they were looking at the
total addressable market what I do
what's the taxi industry yes how many
people have given up their cars exactly
to now use ride-sharing and then you get
into autonomous taxis and you just get
this whole thing it is a market
expansion type opportunity I think that
blockchain is like fix that to a team
now so two questions for you one let's
go to Elon because we talked about a
little bit earlier you reset had on your
podcast yes and he made a whole bunch of
different comments one in particular I
think caught a lot of people off-guard
but excited to crypto community which
was he said paper money's going away
mm-hmm right how do you guys look at
blockchain and cryptocurrency in that
aspect of some of this is there is wind
at the back of crypto and blockchain
right lots of intellectual capital going
in people are building really
interesting things there's some adoption
going
but there's also wind in the face of
some of the legacy you know central
bank's inflation in some countries like
there's almost this opposite effect
happening to two separate parts of the
market that are net positive for crypto
etc and I think he was talking about
crypto is gonna be successful but he's
focused actually first on paper money's
going away yeah we talked about that I'm
not really interesting I I just found it
fascinating he called Bitcoin blockchain
technology a brilliant design design or
structure or something like that hey I
pay attention to him that would that my
confidence level skyrocketed when he
said that just because I take him very
seriously he's a very serious scientist
first principles all the way that you
know spoke volumes to me in terms of the
money side of it you know he probably as
an intellectual and he certainly as that
has focused on this idea that even fiat
currencies we lose 80% of our value
every I don't know a few dozen years and
so that's just wrong that is how can I
change the world kind of thing you know
well that's how he thinks anyway so let
this change the world it is it's one of
the most misunderstood aspects of crypto
in my opinion of let's talk about
Bitcoin specifically the deflationary
nature of true sound money right that is
not governed by a sovereign nation that
can't be printed you know stuff has the
ability to attack the number one cause
of income inequality in the world which
is inflation and when you say regressive
tax yeah and when you start to go after
that just that alone would be a huge yes
and then you layer in on top of it the
programmability
of money you start to almost be
overwhelmed by how big of an opportunity
and
profound yeah before we started you know
I think this is across all five of the
platforms it's more likely that everyone
is under estimating each one of these
then overestimating I couldn't agree
more
so I went through the bubble the
internet bubble and I you're fine you're
okay right
came out alive yes and learned a lot of
lessons and and know what a bubble is
really and we are in the opposite of
that right now
we we're in a the land of despair as far
as I'm concerned in in terms of
innovation okay explain that more what
what that means I feel there's a if you
if you've studied s-curves you you have
or Carlotta Perez's work you have you
know the eruption and frenzy stage then
you have the too much capital chasing
too few opportunities too soon and you
have the fallout so that was the early
2000s and I I think because of oh wait
oh nine that that fear of ever going
back to the late 90s was reinforced then
it was except it was housing but there
was that oh this is what happens and and
I feel as though we still are in the
valley of despair people laugh at me
when I say that I believe we are running
deep value portfolios and you have to
give us the right timeframe if you look
at the multiple on our portfolios a p/e
ratio based on today's earnings 6070
times you know showed up there that's
because we want our companies to be
investing aggressively now because these
opportunities are so big so we are quite
happy that they are doing that as long
as we agree with the strategy and we can
see a minimum 15 percent compound annual
rate of return over five years on
average so we're doubling over five
years and that's a minimum all right we
can see if
the Tesla one got a lot of press because
our bear case is 700 I think it's at
about 300 today
that's our bear case and it meets our
minimum 15% compound algorithm and your
rate of turn bull case is 4,000 everyone
thinks that's crazy but if I gave you
the assumptions behind that I will tell
you given the way we think how the world
is going to work out that is a
conservative bull case for Tesla so
you're gonna love this we have not
talked abouts before so this is exciting
me because one of my theories in crypto
the reason why so much innovation and
interest is coming from the millennial
generation is that they were told
stories in their early teens and mid
teens about the internet bubble they did
not experience it they weren't aware I'm
dead square right in the middle of that
demographic and then we went through the
housing crisis and the global financial
crisis and we're just aware enough to
see what happened know that there was a
lot of people who did irresponsible
things probably see either our families
or people around us be affected in a
very negative way but not have enough
assets to actually be personally
affected mm-hmm and that left a bad
taste of distrust in everyone's mouth in
that generation and now all of a sudden
we're moving into a world where somebody
has come along and said there's a new
piece of technology that not only allows
you to do the same things that people
have always told you that you could do
you don't have to have the false trust
in those organizations right my parents
never thought a bank would go out right
now that that would be unfastened and
then that was my experience growing up
of course he's basically fine I didn't
think could fail right and so it feels
to me like not only does innovation
happen from earlier stages etc the stat
that I recently came out eToro did this
study and it says that 43 percent of
Millennials that they surveyed
trust the crypto exchanges more than
traditional stock markets mm-hmm oh well
Christian Carlo at the CFTC I'm sure you
saw the Testament his first testimony on
this in in front of some committee he
was with J Clayton at the time he said
ok I gotta get this right because I
tried to educate inspire my children to
invest in equities and bonds when they
were in high school and they just had
never had any interest now they're in
their 20s they're on their own and
they're coming to me asking me about
this asset about cryptocurrency about
crypto assets generally and so what I
liked about his testimony is he believes
this is real innovation and is to be
taken seriously do no harm I think is
the philosophy but it was his children
and just like Jamie diamonds daughter
finally got him to stop bad-mouthing at
least all of the cryptos but I did want
to say one thing one of the reasons I'm
so excited about this movement is I was
educated by art Laffer art Laffer many
people know him for the Laffer curve
which is a fiscal policy consequent
which is if you increase taxes enough
you'll get less in the way of revenues
because people will just not work or
move or whatever but he is a global
monetary scholar ok his mentor was
Robert Mandel who won a Nobel Prize for
economics and we collaborated on our
first Bitcoin paper together so arc was
the first public asset manager to gain
exposure to Bitcoin in 2015 ok so
there's gonna be one of my questions
explain what you guys did then and what
the logic was at that point and then we
tore what you doing today sure so what
we did is Chris had joined the firm he
was next generation internet analyst
okay and our director of research Brett
Winton and
i but brett more so he was onto this
well before i was we were saying okay
let's let's just see if it could fulfill
the roles of money and i said let's get
art Laffer to write that paper with us
because he's a professor and he will not
let us get away with anything so we were
I'm not saying we were skeptical or not
skeptical we were just trying to figure
out what this was could it serve the
roles of money and the the we wrote that
paper and with art art never put his
name on any other paper associated with
crypto anything so I'm really proud of
that
but he was my professor at USC and
really tough really good really tough
and he put us through the wringer I mean
we had to think about this so I was
going back to my he was in the graduate
school at USC I was going back to those
classes and you know just really
drilling down and making sure we had our
t's crossed Izod and all of that when we
finished doing that paper I said what I
said to art I said art how big could
this be and he said well how big is the
u.s. monetary base and at that time it
was four point five trillion dollars I
said
Wow so it was through that period we
were also watching Greece was
threatening to leave the euro and we
were watching Bitcoin settle on its 200
week moving average and you know just
because Bloomberg comes equipped with
these lines I look at them because
everybody looks at them so okay look at
them
and but we were watching and I was
watching how it was responding to the
news on Greece and it was starting to
respond and so I said okay let's do this
and so we put it on the portfolio's in
September okay remember what size
position you guys stood we were only
allowed by the regulators to put in one
percent position okay and we let it ride
we didn't so we said okay
we didn't say we would keep it there no
don't don't tell them I'm kidding I'm
kidding
[Laughter]
did you know by the way we never did buy
anymore we let it run we never sold any
was 10 percent decision ran and we
cannot we could not hold any position
above 10 position in that was delivering
unqualified income so that was and
especially because it had started
working and we were getting these
unqualified income questions so we
needed to fiduciary had to make sure
when we did take the size down it
happened to be good timing
it was around the peak we took it back
down to one got it so one you know it's
not public that we raise some money from
some public pensions to gonna do crypto
space to the first two to do it we also
got some money from hospital system and
insurance company and things like that
and the conversations that we found most
or kind of had the most attraction we're
not about crypto
it wasn't about decentralized in the
world you know burned down walls yeah
because it was about you have an asset
that has load to no correlation it has
an asymmetric return program if you
believe in Modern Portfolio theory you
probably should put the system portfolio
right and here's all the impact and
the benefits and some downsides and all
that did you guys think through that or
was it more of your making a bet on the
growth of the asset no we thought
through it now so our first paper was
could it serve the role of money okay
okay that was the first paper we didn't
talk about our research ecosystem
earlier but our research ecosystem is
very open and we were pushing that paper
out and we were only a year old only a
year old
I mean fledgling yeah and coinbase
reaches out to Kris over Twitter because
we're pushing our research on Twitter
and LinkedIn and medium wherever we can
you actually were dropping pamphlets on
the sidewalk outside wherever we can
engage with the communities we're
researching that's where we want to be
and we want them to see our research
we're the first sharing economy company
we believe in the asset management space
when it comes to research here's the
payback in 2015 coin base
diems Chris and they got to know each
other a little bit then coinbase
proposes to Chris that we arc and
coinbase write a white paper together
about this new asset class for exactly
the reason you just said and Chris comes
back to me and says this is what they
want to do and I said why do they want
to do that with us why don't they go to
Goldman or Morgan Stanley you know
Goldman's gonna want to do their deal
when they go when they IPO what's why us
and it was and this is what transparency
does it's because we have real
credibility we wrote that paper we were
validating it when most of the
traditional financial community was
considering it or considering the
possibility it could be a Ponzi scheme
we come out and say no it's real it's
not yeah and that paper was called
Bitcoin ringing the bell for a new asset
class we could not have written that
paper without the data that coinbase
gave
so this research ecosystem that we have
evolved sharing economy it spoke volumes
to me it worked so much better and so
much sooner than I had anticipated
that was a very important moment for us
so okay so I really want to talk about
this cuz this is me being selfish and
learning from you in something it's
directly applicable
I've thought a ton about what is wrong
in the asset management business less
about people being inaccurate and
investing and things like that but more
about the company building side and how
many of the legacy firms are built for a
well that doesn't exist anymore and you
are so right and some of its speed some
of its transparency communication all
stuff but what you guys have done
there's a lot of things that I'm envious
of frankly in terms of your ability to
cultivate a community to provide more
transparency than your regulatory
required to the way that you communicate
and disseminate information and kind of
give much more than you take from these
communities it has a lot of advantages
and so we're very early on and trying to
do this stuff probably taking a less
research and academic side and more
audience building etc but I'd love to
hear now that you're five years in and
you can take that exhale and say okay we
made in five years what you've learned
along the way and kind of would you do
it again right and kind of what those
benefits have been as you've built the
company would I do it again without a
doubt
I actually am hoping others do this as
well because I believe that we are in
the middle of the most massive
misallocation of capital in the history
of mankind what is called passive and
indexed investing it's just wrong what's
wrong it's very backwards looking and
what are you know when I was starting
the company I was speaking to a person
who knew
thing about my our business and I was
trying to explain to him not being in
our business what I was trying to do and
he said oh so you mean the future of
investing is investing in the future yes
because that that we've lost the plot
when I started and I started when I was
in college in the late 70s
there were no complete - anyway so there
were no computers no one had a computer
no net certainly no cell phones nothing
information was scarce I worked at
Capital Group on the west coast just a
wonderful institution and I remember my
first I was my first meeting I was
sitting with the economists because art
Laffer introduced me to the company
Thank You art again and I was listening
to a group from Asia and the US and
Europe talked about Hong Kong this is
1997
I mean 1977 about Hong Kong 1997 20
years later when the changeover was
going to take place and I was saying oh
man I want to be a part of this business
I want to do this I want to understand
how the world is going to work and so
that's why I joined and back then going
into companies it was so hard to get
information that there was a real role
for those company visits and you know
going to conferences and everything now
the information is just out there and by
the way they can't tell you anything
they haven't told everybody else so you
can't it's not like inside information
was ok back then it was the only way to
do to invest was to try and get some
information to bring perspective well
the information edge was available with
the company's information absolutely now
that's been taken away by regulation
and the information advantage has to
come from non company sources and so
from our point of view the information
advantage is in doing first principles
research again not being done many
people ask us who else is doing what
you're doing no one else is doing what
we're doing if you look at our models we
now have autonomous taxi Network models
five years old and they're evolving and
we see the price of autonomous travel
coming down as other prices come down so
we have autonomous truck platoons we
have drones we have passenger drones and
parcel drones and so forth
we've done all that modeling work and
the aha moment for me on this in terms
of you're doing the right thing
was when in 2014 we put out our first
drone piece where we said you know
Amazon could deliver a five-pound
package over a 10 mile radius for $1
profitably today if the regulators would
let them that went out and here we were
this little peep out of a company maybe
we have 20 million dollars probably not
under management and and yet Silicon
Valley ran with that because they
haven't seen that work before so we're
doing that kind of work and trying to
help people understand how big these
opportunities are and maybe even help
regulators hopefully understand as well
our research is getting into I know
we've done work with the Port Authority
here in New York and in New Jersey so
it's starting to get out there because
we want people to understand yeah this
is gonna save lives are this gonna save
money the best thing that can happen for
us this is going to sound odd but is a
crisis and that's it's always the best
thing for innovation it's usually when
innovation takes root and gains traction
so in oh wait oh nine when technology
chief technology officers were told by
their CEO and CFO cut you're spending
another twenty or thirty percent they
had been cutting since the tech and
telecom busts they couldn't cut anymore
what did they do
they stopped using the enterprise-level
license license software and went to
pay-as-you-go
so while most tech technology companies
saw their revenues drop 10 20 30 % at
some point during the period
salesforce.com zwarst quarter of growth
worst quarter of revenue growth was 20%
it's incredible
it is incredible so that's why we lean
aggressively into our highest conviction
names when there is a crisis so we
concentrate more while others are
diversifying more we concentrate because
we know we know that these companies are
going to gain traction and take off well
there's a lot that goes into that right
it's like I think it's the Warren
Buffett quote where he basically says
diversification is for people who don't
know what they're doing right and so
like when there's a bunch of fear and
people are kind of got whiplash and oh
my god the world's ending yeah that's
what you do right you go into
preservation mode you go into defense
and then you go to your salute and by
the way that is not what you should do
in our view don't want anyone to confuse
that and instead the companies that are
going to survive first you got to be
right on the companies are going to
survive but if you are right if you
actually can build highly concentrated
positions in those times it will pay off
when you right now market hugely right
that is the secret to our out
performance over time mm-hmm
I always say when we're in the middle of
a shall we say turbulent period
fourth-quarter was a bit fat and our
analyst team is young very young because
they have one foot in the new world
they've been educated in these areas and
they're passionate about pursuing them
iö and so they've not been through very
many bad markets and I'll always say ok
you got it
first of all very calm okay this is when
we're going to this is when we're what
is good this is the period that's going
to determine how much we're going to
outperform going forward so let's
concentrate let's
it is it's funny to me how investing is
very similar to sports in some ways in
that if you look at all the great cost
football coaches right and NFL coaches
many of them there's these videos online
and when things are going bad they're
kind of somber when things are going
well the scoring the touchdown
they're somber president Bill Belichick
they yeah with the pages of great symbol
like people are excited when they catch
him on video
smiling like he's pretty even keel good
times bad time frames just kind of hey
we're here to do a job and investing is
very similar to not only the bear
markets it's also in the ball more
absolutely you guys probably more so
than others talk about you sell into the
bear absence Bowl markets right so maybe
talk about how you think about the bear
market is probably talked about too much
I know if you can get creative people
are fearful etc but going into a bull
market I think that's actually when
people lose even more discipline because
they get really greedy right and so what
we do is diversify into a bull market as
it extends because we're usually
involved in stocks where you know if
people do get it they do that stocks do
take off and you know I've been again
around the block a few times I I know I
know what is too much you know even with
Bitcoin as it was levitating it was
interesting I was even kind of examining
my own thoughts about this like why why
haven't you taken more profits why
aren't you doing that and part of it is
we were trying to figure out tax
ramifications so we were thinking about
it throughout the fourth quarter of 17
and we were trying to manage around it
but where we had where we didn't have a
tax consideration other other accounts
we did take it down by half okay we took
half of our position out in the in
December actually was December and there
we left it so we took it down to a four
and a half five percent position now
would have said well that was pretty
stupid we have we didn't add to it as it
was going down but we did add to it as
it got to sort of the well six thousand
and then three thousand where the
milestones were waiting for because I
just who knows where where it's going to
turn just yeah no idea the um we can
talk about this for hours
oh one thing I want to go back to is so
we went through the five platforms right
we started off talking about how most
firms have very siloed approaches so if
you're into DNA sequencing right in kind
of the healthcare life sciences that's
what you study right and that's what you
look at if you're into robotics battery
storage all stuff you look at a lot of
things that don't fit in those buckets
so you've identified five platforms hmm
but you've talked quite a bit about
autonomous taxi networks mm-hmm so maybe
let's talk about that specific
application of multiple technologies and
how you one just describe what that
means and kind of how you know why
you're excited about etc but then to how
do you use a fairly rigid framework of
five specific platforms to look at a
application of those technologies that
doesn't fit in any one five right it's
kind of a blend across multiple ones
right it's the working assumption that
these platforms are converging okay so
if you have if you're setting up a
company like this and that is your
belief what you will do is create a very
open atmosphere so I'm right in the
middle of all the research and we're all
talking to each other listening to each
other because very often what one
analyst is saying even in the
genomespace you'd be surprised how much
artificial intelligence is impacting
that space now and it is you know when
you combine that with DNA sequencing
which is the source of the data and
artificial intelligence and computing
power there's some mind-blowing stuff
going on and it's just really fun to
hear about that
so if you the way we're set up is every
day we have a morning meeting because
there's always something new happening
and you I might come on your podcast and
say that paperwhite is going and so you
have the morning meeting every morning
where we're just batting back-and-forth
just news items anything that came out
there's relevant to anything that we're
doing right and that sometimes will
spark discussion so I won't do anything
usually no meetings until earliest 10:00
maybe 10:30 so from 7:30 to 10:30 is
when we just really power down you know
because again the world is changing very
quickly so that's the first thing we
also have a brainstorm a session you'd
be more than welcome to join us every
Friday from 1:00 to 3:00 okay
and that is where analysts under the
leadership of Brett went in our director
of research the analysts submit to Brett
the most interesting or provocative or
controversial ideas they've heard all
week or the biggest breakthrough they've
had in their own research Oh interesting
yeah and then we will put that out for
brainstorm discussion and so Brett and I
are involved all of the analysts are
involved whereas in the morning meeting
some people it'll perk they're at peak
their interest and others this is a
really concentrated hey let's let's see
if we can come up with some aha moments
that's what I call them in here so in
2014 when Nvidia is being thrown out of
most portfolios because it was a PC
proxy and nothing more than a PC gaming
chip pump company tasha keaney comes in
and says you know she's charged with
building the model for our autonomous
taxi network well first we need an
autonomous taxi right so hoho so
autonomous vehicles it looks like GPUs
are going to be the brains or the
central nervous system of autonomous
taxis and I'm sitting there saying Tasha
are you sure no one knows that no I've
never heard anyone say that no one out
there is talking about this and she said
yep and then we we went through the
research and then James who was in the
same meeting he's out of Nvidia himself
and he says well that makes a lot of
sense because Nvidia or GPUs are
essential for the training side of
artificial intelligence and I said okay
James you know that because you worked
at Nvidia and you see the pipeline but I
guarantee you the financial markets do
not know this and so we felt we had a
leg up right there and in video went up
in the size of Nvidia went up in our
portfolios and it entered other
portfolios it entered our industrial
innovation portfolio for example so the
collaborative nature of the way we've
set we're set up physically and and what
we do in terms of setting our various
meetings up we have a research modeling
session so I'll come in and see how the
sausage is being made on Thursdays and
that's where we meet with Brett and I
meet with each of the research teams
each one takes us through the latest
development in their modeling now I'm
not there every week because it takes a
long time to make this sausage and I can
catch up pretty quickly but I would like
to do that because that's the source of
my confidence right there's a lot of
people saying wow you're so brave and no
it's the courage of conviction born out
of great research great original first
principle based principles based
research which there is not that right
out there anymore the biggest surprise
to me
I thought venture capital firms did this
I did until I started the business now
they want to partner with us which is
really interesting and gratifying and
we're happy we do have I'll tell you the
secret that you probably already know
venture capitalists are the biggest
sheep in the world
look it is I have a theory that I want
your opinion on actually the more that
there is consensus excitement about an
early-stage company the less interested
I seem we've been asked if we will enter
the venture capital space and I say
only under one condition that we only
buy into companies that nobody else is
excited about they have the right
technology we have been looking for a
company with that technology maybe they
don't have the most charismatic CEOs or
whatever and can't schmooze but they
have the right technology you know we
just have to make sure the right
business leaders around them
I could see doing that but I think the
biggest excess is the bubble today is in
venture capital and in the private
markets and really I don't want anything
to do with it right now
I want the allocation of capital if you
look at the misallocation of capital you
look at in the 3d printing space
Stratasys it's about maybe now it's
about two times sales okay
foreign labs in the private space last
round which means the deal will be
higher than this the IPO or what next
round ten and a half times sales okay so
two and a half the public market ten and
a half times sales that's the last round
I'm sure it's going higher Stratasys is
much better positioned because it is now
being integrated into aerospace
companies engines right you think that
an aerospace company is going to allow a
start-up to design as a part for its
engines pretty unlikely you have to get
battle tested over a number of years
right it's taken a long time for
Stratasys so they're in a much better
position I don't understand this I can
give you other ones Palantir at its peak
last round was twenty six times and the
bankers were gonna take it for fifty
five times
Splunk which is a better model is that
nine times you know so we could so that
that bubble is going to end and it's
going to end badly I don't know exactly
how I do know this this I did not know
until recently and it blew my mind if if
this really is true I was talking to the
CEO of a 3d printing company who was
saying oh yeah you know we know and that
the stock had been creamed and he said
yeah a few a few companies
are thinking about IP owing and and
we've heard about some of their
public-private holders so those holders
who are maybe the big like fidelity's or
TIROS I don't know who this is I'm not
casting aspersions or anything that
they're in the pre IPO market but
they're shorting in the in the public
market because they know that their deal
is going to go badly it's too
high-priced given the valuations and the
public markets are they're shorting in
the public markets even though there's
this discrepancy and you know what I did
see that play out in the are nai space
in the genomic space we have a company
to time sales madura the name is
Arcturus Madonna went public on December
6th at 30 times sales it promptly got
cut in half went from 26 to 13 and it
hurt our company to our company got 40
comes yeah what you just described in
terms of the process that you run with
this research on Fridays we're bring
your wildest ideas the most
controversial and throw them out there
it reminds me of a quote innovation is
born out of necessity and what you're
doing is I think this is true
I've heard that BuzzFeed at some point
in their life when someone would write
an article they had to come up with 25
headlines for that article okay and so
the first five breezy ten okay some
variation of the first five right
eventually you run out of the easy ones
and you really start stretching right
you know this is where you get some of
the click baby headlines and you're
really stretching and they would take
those 25 headlines and they would load
them in to a system that would basically
show all 25 headlines to some small
percentage of the audience and then
whichever one got the most clicks they
would then blast that on the main site
to everyone right the reason why I bring
this up is I forget the exact number now
we should remember I think it's like the
last five or the last seven we're almost
always or some high percentage of the
time the ones that
when they were put into that system
because they were the most non-obvious
yes people had to pick yeah and so if I
know that every Friday I got to come to
a research session I might get to
Thursday night and oh she said I don't
have anything and I start calling up
some pretty wild stuff to show people
and so it's the way that people design
firms and the way that they think
through the interaction of their staff
and structure everything it does have a
huge in dose the information output that
you and the chemistry I mean every time
we add a person I mean it is that's it's
got to be top of mind for me because the
chemistry and this six segalis from
Janice and associates where I was for 18
years he used to say this he used to he
hated the interview process because he
knew that the odds that this next person
very talented probably you know
strong-willed probably all those things
you do want those things can harm the
chemistry and culture of an organization
so the way we do our hiring is if we're
looking for an analyst I am NOT the
first screen our analysts are the first
screen and then Brett and then I am and
I actually I have again around the track
a few times I I can spout a few things
that are just absolutely not
and I'm learning to trust myself more on
that too it was a feeling uh no one's
ever fired somebody too quickly right
it's true all right before uh before we
wrap up I usually ask a whole bunch of
rapid-fire questions I'm gonna skip a
bunch of them because they don't matter
but I have two questions and then you
get to ask me a question so think
through that for a second but first
question what's the most important book
you've ever read okay well investment
book you mean in any book in the well
then this is going to tell you a lot
about my life the Bible and it is so
it is and actually still is I go back to
it all the time you were only the second
person to ever say that on it really
yeah at first I actually my hunch is
that more people believe that that is
the most important book they've ever
read they don't want to say ah
so III have no way to prove that yeah
but that's that's my general take cuz
people usually come in and they will hit
me with every book that you and I have
seen go around the Olympic or the
intellectual Olympics of Twitter right
that is supposedly you can be the next
thing that saves the world all right
a non tech question aliens what is the
probability that they exist versus not
existent wow I've never thought of that
I have to be open to almost anything in
terms of what I do okay how would you
work through trying to get to some
probability I'd get bread our director
and our analyst together let's think
through this that's it let's think
through this no honestly I'll ask that
this is this is gonna be one of the
topics at our brainstorm I'm friend it
come I was just gonna say I'm cheating
because I get to participate without
actually having to go the reason why I
usually ask I actually want to know the
outcome of this is it's fascinating to
hear people try to think through it and
arrive at different answers and some
people walk in and artists like you know
answers I would never believe like Josh
Brown believes that ghosts are more
likely than aliens so him and I haven't
been talking crazy now but uh but it's
one of these things we're not that many
people have ever thought about the
probability behind yeah right you see
the movie you see no stuff and I usually
ask what is the probability that aliens
have pets because a lot of times in
movies we think of the
other intelligent life it's just a human
comparison yeah right they show up
rather like slimy maybe a little shorter
weird head shape whatever but are they
actually multi species you know type
intelligent life out there probably as I
said I have to be open to anything and
then we do our first principles research
all right you're gonna come back at some
point yes we will
okay we will all right well one question
do you have for me oh gosh well I want
to know are you leaning more towards
given given what you're building here
are you alright you love building this
community you want to educate I presume
is this an institutional and retail
investor base all institutional okay all
institutional and my whole theory is
that this is the secret sauce is we will
benefit more from doing everything
possible to build an industry that
doesn't have direct benefit to us then
we will from wrapping our arms and say
we're gonna go take our ball and go play
different sandbox that's why we set up a
research ecosystem in the same way so
that's fantast some of the things that I
will caveat all of this with we have not
decided to do this these are my personal
ideas I have no clue my partner's think
about this but things that I do think
are very interesting and different what
if we actually published all of our
investment memos all the companies we
invested in the private market what if
we publish our returns and you can
literally go see the nav of the fund
what if we were to announce in very
different ways investments we made how
would sound errs look at that positively
negatively what are the risks right the
regulation is all stuff how do we
incorporate a retail audience that's
very big it's very engaged much more
into what we're doing while still being
compliant and aware of all that
regulation it blows my mind I could pick
my phone up right that little computer
in my pocket and talk to 180,000 people
and just type it out BAM and it goes
yeah and then they share with people and
it just and goes viral how do you take
that and bring it in to what
historically is been a pretty private
business right right and kind of closed
off and not only how does that help us
but crypto is this weird area where the
thing that unites crypto the most is
actually people outside crypto attacking
it always this is all scam yeah Jimmy I
saw skip yeah immediately everybody who
hates each other really becomes friends
links arms sounds like no we're coming
right and so how do you take that like
fanatical belief and interest and energy
and energy and directed towards things
that I don't need to build Morgan Creek
I want to build an entire industry where
there's 20 of us 30 50 of us right
because I'm only gonna raise so much
money for institutions right you guys
are only gonna raise so much money from
retail institutions to go invest in
Bachchan like we need hundreds at some
point right we'll do this but I think
that community is very undervalued and
underutilized we're fortunate enough to
have it what do we do with it right
right that's like the big question and I
just keep coming back to and so we've
done everything from you know look we in
probably unpopular fashion valley knots
to fund we announced who the Opie's work
uh-huh now their pensions right so
they're gonna be it's gonna be public
information at some point but but doing
that we announced our entire portfolio
that's not very common right we've done
things where we've lived on these like
flash sales of t-shirts would you fund
managers doing selling t-shirts you're
missing the point the point is there's
now
people walking around and they feel like
they're part they're part of the
community they feel like this t-shirt I
have on is a statement of what I believe
in Who I am and then they are showing it
to the hundreds of people they interact
with
Moe and shirt that's that's a lot of
stuff vesting and they are going to
bring you ideas they if you make them
feel a part of your community your
ecosystem they will give you more ideas
you strengthen the community look I'll
say right now if you guys are watching
and you made it all the way to the end
thank you
but tweet at Cathy and I the wildest
ideas you have in blockchain and I will
have some fun and engage with you guys
but listen thank you so much this has
been awesome we're gonna have to do this
much more often yeah yeah I'm gonna
sneak in on Fridays and let's do you can
video but yes thank you so much a
pleasure thank you thank you so much